hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
talken welt bevor es heute weiter zu
meiner rezept geht möchte ich mich erst
mal bei euch allen bedanken
ich hab mir zu nehmen ich schon über
5000 abonnenten bei youtube und fast
5000 gleich bei facebook und außerdem
habe ich fast 300.000 klicks und video
abrufe bei youtube und ich finde es
einfach unfassbar wie viel ich schon im
letzten jahr erreicht habe ich bin ja
noch nicht mal ein jahr bei youtube mit
dabei und freue mich eigentlich jedes
mal wieder video zu drehen
ohne euch wäre es nämlich gar nicht so
weit gekommen ich freue mich jedes mal
wenn ihr meine videos kommentiert
bewertet mir feedback gibt und meine
rezepte natürlich auch nach kocht denn
das richtige dabei ich möchte sehr
machen damit ich euch zum backen zu
kochen inspirieren kann und macht
einfach weiter so ich freue mich jedes
mal drauf und für heute etwas ganz
besonderes ausgesucht draußen kommt
jetzt langsam der frühling und ich
möchte jetzt den frühling auch nach
hause holen
deswegen habe ich nach einer idee
gesucht und nach einer inspiration und
war deswegen den zeitschriftenhandel und
mir da dieser magazine durch zuschauen
und ein magazin schneller ganz besonders
aufgefallen und zwar ist es diese suite
von 10
das ist ein code & style magazin
und mir ist einfach ins auge gefallen
weil es diese farben die auf dem cover
zu sehen sind
die fand ich so schön hier mit diesen
macarons und dieses magazin
habe ich dann gesehen erscheint alle
drei teams einfach so tolle sachen drin
ich habe damals umgeblättert
ihr seht auch meine ganze kostet möchte
ich unbedingt noch ausprobieren und ich
habe mich erstaunt so richtig
entscheiden können was ich salz davon
machen soll sind ein hohn zitronen torte
ein sohn oder diese biskuitrolle vom
cover und letztendlich habe ich mich
jetzt für eine zitrone für einen
zitronenkuchen entschieden weil er
einfach schnell geht und was ich hier
hinten noch ganz toll wird das sind zum
beispiel salate
falls euch das interessiert würde ich
das auch gerne nachmachen und zwar
sowohl farblich bestimmt also hier
gelber salat grüner salat
da haben sie denn meistens alarms
schwarzen fahrrad weiter vorne gab es
mit den roten und gelben und ja was euch
das interessiert meldet euch einfach das
mache ich auch nach und jetzt sag ich
aber mal nicht in zitronenkuchen machen
und dazu stelle ich euch selbst anderem
eine zutaten für den teig braucht ihr
fünf eier in crystal ich habe jetzt
getrennt es braucht ihr gleich nicht so
machen ich hätte ja auch gleich wieso
dann habe ich hier 150 gramm zucker oder
20 gramm mehl 2 teelöffel backpulver
eine bio zitrone von der verwende ich
gleich die schale und etwas saft eine
kleine prise salz rund 180 gramm und was
ich ganz toll an diesem heft findet muss
ich noch erwähnen
diese zutaten die man auch für die
rezepte benutzt die sind eigentlich
überall erhältlich in jedem supermarkt
und die meisten hat man sogar schon zu
hause und das finde ich eigentlich immer
ganz gut gerade was und sachen
nachmachen möchte die sehen ja immer
ganz toll aus aber meistens hinter
zutaten drin die man eigentlich nirgends
erhalten
und das finde ich an diesen magazinen
ganz große entweder habt ihr die zutaten
daheim oder ihr könnt sie einfach
supermarkt kaufen
ihr könnt jetzt schon mal den ofen auf
175 grad ober unterhitze vorhalten
und dann könnt ihr schon mal die form
vorbereiten und zwar nehme ich jetzt so
eine ganz normale google book vor
ihr könnt jeder andere springform nehmen
wir jetzt einfach möchte ich habe da
jetzt etwas unter eingegeben und habt
ihr ganz kurz in den ofen gestellt damit
ich das jetzt schon verteilen kann
[Musik]
und es ist ja echt fertig machen
hier ist nämlich auch schon mal passiert
dafür bis kuchen oder zusammen und die
hälfte des kuchens an den hängen
geblieben ist und das ist eigentlich
ziemlich ärgerlich in alle ecken und
dann nehme ich mir noch etwas mehl und
bestäuber die form damit da gehe ich
richtig auf nummer sicher auch gar
nichts gehen bleibt auch hier die
mädchen nicht verlassen und in kleine
rechnung ist einfach nicht zu meinem ele
zu und braucht jetzt auch nicht
wegducken so die vhs vorbereitet und
stellt sie kurz zur seite so lange sich
den teig vorbereitet
also ich bin uns jetzt haben eine
küchenmaschine ihr könnt es natürlich
auch mit jedem anderen
handvoll gerät machen und im rezept wird
eigentlich beschrieben dass man eigelb
und eiweiß getrennt voneinander verrührt
also eiweiß steif schlagen aber das
braucht ihr eigentlich gar nicht geht so
nämlich viel schneller
jetzt gebe ich einfach die eier hier
rein also eigelb und eiweiß
da kommt jetzt noch die prise salz mehr
dazu und das lasse ich jetzt auf
höchster stufe verrühren und las
währenddessen den zucker eingelegt
[Musik]
die ein weisses schäumchen maschine
abstellen
ich habe zuletzt zwischenzeit schon mal
die zitrone ab geräten die
zitronenschale und ich habe vorher
gesagt dass ich eine bio zitrone ist
einfach drauf achten damit die schale
nicht gespritzt ist und ihr diese ganzen
stoffe dann nicht später in euren kuchen
haft deswegen legt er wert drauf dass
ich mir die bio zitrone kaufe die kosten
zwar ein paar cent mehr
aber die sich einem eigentlich mehr und
dann geht's weiter mit dem teig und zwar
gegen uns das backpulver zum mehl mit
dazu verwenden da jetzt nicht nur die
zitronenschale sondern auch den
zitronensaft dazu nehme ich jetzt
einfach die zitrone und klaviere und ich
werde immer ganz häufig gefragt woher
ich meine zitronenpresse habe das ist ne
zitronenpresse presse von louis
ich glaube zieht ronaldo heißt die
unterstellt man die zitrone einfach oben
rein und kann sie dann mit der hand
ausdrücken ohne dass die hand track ich
wird und wenn die zitrone nicht dann
ausgepresst wird macht man den deckel
drauf und kann sich so in den
kühlschrank stellen oder eben weg
stellen in den kühlschrank stellen
normalerweise traum ja nicht so dass
spritze ich jetzt einmal hier in genf in
die zuckermasse
und dann kann man es zitronen bis zum
letzten tropfen selbst ausdrücken und
dann einfach zitrone raus und die
nächste zitrone ein hinweis den saft von
der ganzen zitrone ich mag es ganz gern
ich mag's ganzen zitronig jetzt kann man
sehen dass oben was raus spritzt wenn
sich unten im kern festgesetzt hat den
müsste einfach entfernen
dann kommt noch die zitronenschale mit
rein das öl
ich habe jetzt geschmacksneutral
sonnenblume benutzt ihr könnt natürlich
an olivenöl benutzen aber das schmeckt
man dann später
und da noch vorsichtig das mehl mit
backpulver und jetzt wird es einfach
ganz kurz berührt bis das mehl und die
trockenen zutaten mit ca
können sie die maschine ausschalten
ich gucke ob sich unten nicht noch mehr
festgesetzt hat das passiert bei den
maschinen
[Musik]
er zeigt einfach in die vorbereitete
ich benutze allen rezepten auch im
freiland eier oder bio eier aus
bodenhaltung verzicht ich generell weil
ich einfach die tiere über nacht gerecht
findet und ich habe auch in meine bei
youtube immer noch playlist die sendung
von jamie oliver james hühner hülle
eingesetzt da könnt ihr euch mal
anschauen
dann nämlich von haya diese sendung
gemacht über die eier und hühner
industrie berichtet und sich selbst sagt
ich denke wir euch das mal anschaut wird
keiner von euch da draußen bodenhaltung
einkaufen sondern eher so freiland oder
bio eier tendieren einkommen ist jetzt
soweit fertig also der teig und jetzt
kommt das ganze bei 175 grad etwa 45
minuten in den ofen
ich mache aber noch die stäbchen tobe
und sage euch danach wie lange ich genau
gebraucht werden der kuchen backt
bereite ich schon mal die kandierten
zitrone zu und zwar könnt ihr hier auf
dem wir uns ganz gut sehen
das ist ja diese zitronenkuchen den ich
mache und die zitronen darauf sind
kandiert die macht mal selber ich habe
ich hier noch mal 230 gramm zucker und
240 milliliter wasser und nehme jetzt
zwei bis drei zitronen eine bio zitrone
sieht man auch keines zitrone sieht aus
wie die andere
aber das macht eigentlich nur noch
sympathischer jetzt nehmt ihr euch die
zitronen das ende schneidet hier weg und
schneidet sie in dünne scheiben
ich würde mal sagen so einen halben
zentimeter dick
oder 3 bis 4 mm gedacht
nehmt ihr euch einfach mal einen kleinen
topf da kommen jetzt die citroen rhein
sieht die kerle die herausbekommt könnt
ihr gerne raus polen
der rest stört wie ich jetzt eigentlich
netz
ich hoffe nur dass du damit wieder
schmecken dann kommen die jetzt einfach
rein dann kommt da der zucker trauer und
das wasser und es wartet jetzt auf dem
herd bei mittlerer hitze etwa 20 minuten
köcheln lassen
ich stehe da gleich die kamera noch mit
dazu dann könnt ihr das ganze buch
komische gedanken 40 gruppen gebraucht
so sieht es aus ich habe jetzt schon mal
auf meine kurven platte gestürzt da ich
noch ziemlich warm deswegen job die
platte etwas geschlagen den dass ich
jetzt so einmal komplett abkühlen
die trocken platte mit dem deckel oben
habe ich übrigens zehn euro gekauft
den ohren stellen
[Musik]
jahrhundert
minuten bei mittlerer hitze köcheln
lassen und so sieht es jetzt aus
also es hat sich etwas dunkel verfärbt
und das müsste jetzt eigentlich mal
riechen das riecht so schön zitrone und
[Musik]
her und eine gabe und mädels da die
zitronenscheiben raus manche haben es
nicht ganz heil überstanden und das
macht aber nix und kandierte zitronen
heißt ja einfach die zucker den zitronen
nur dass sie schön abkühlen können
ihr könnt den teil natürlich auch
weglassen ihr könnt in zitronenkuchen
auch banken ohne die könnte jetzt die
zitronen obendrauf zu geben könnten auch
eine ganz normale zuckerglasur machen
habe ich euch ja schon mal in anderen
video gezeigt und so hat sich das jetzt
einmal abkühlen jetzt verarbeitet auf
den kuchen weiter
hier habe ich noch eine übrig gebliebene
sehr hoch ich probierte noch mal
da schmeckt richtig schön zitronig und
süß auch leicht säuerlich und dem rezept
steht drin dass man eben noch ein paar
tropfen von dem sirup auf den kuchen
teufeln kann zuerst wo ich nicht machen
aber so schmeckte kuchen dann noch etwas
zitrone auf frischer passt also zum
frühling und auch zum sommer und
deswegen werde ich das auch machen und
ich empfehle euch das auf jeden fall
nach zu machen einfach aufpassen dass
hier keine kerne erwischt und dann ganz
leicht über den kuchen geben ich würde
es auch nicht so viel machen ein paar
tropfen
es reicht
und fand ich eigentlich noch bis die
kandierten zitronen abgekühlt sind dann
lege ich dir nun schon irgendwo auf und
dann sind wir auch schon fertig und dem
restlichen sehr gut denn müsst ihr
übrigens nicht wegschmeißen
ihr lasst uns einfach abkühlen und dann
könnt ihr später etwas die russin glas
geben und mich kannte mineralwasser
aufhören dann habt ihr eine übernahme
hergestellt
meine zitronenscheiben sind etwas
abgekühlt und ich werde jetzt schön auf
dem kuchen dekorieren
ich sage euch auch noch einmal das
original sin magazin zu sehen und zwar
was ist hier so zu sehen
einfach schön übereinander gelegt und so
welches jetzt hier einfach auch mit
anrichten nicht so mit dafür natürlich
die schönsten zitronenscheiben raus und
mach eventuell noch ein paar körner raus
aber das kann später einfach die sma
vielleicht auch darauf achten dass der
größenunterschied nicht so groß ist wenn
sie nebeneinander legen
mein feld die version des citroen aus
ich hoffe es hat euch spaß gemacht mir
beim video zuzuschauen und ich kann mich
einfach nur empfehlen dieses mal
durchzublättern und das genaue rezept
könnt ihr natürlich dann auf dem in dem
heft finden oder ihr geht auf die
internetseite von sweet paul ich glaube
die heißt www es mit paul de und falls
euch noch weitere rezepte interessiert
aus diesem heft lasst es mich wissen ich
weiß auf jeden fall nach machen und ich
mach später aufgestanden geschmackstest
und welches natürlich berichten wie mit
den kuchen geschmeckt hat und dann
wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
in germany
wie das denn zu